the Museum of the Bible opens Saturday
in Washington DC it cost five hundred
million dollars making it the largest
properly funded museum in the city a big
part of that money comes from the
conservative Christian family-run
company Hobby Lobby chip Reid is at the
four hundred and thirty thousand square
foot museum just blocked from the
Capitol chip good morning as you can see
this is a museum of biblical proportions
it's one of the biggest in this city of
museums even bigger than the massive Air
and Space Museum the people who build it
say it's the most complicated project
they've ever done and Washington
politics made it even more so you can
have a lot of sore necks in this place
at 140 feet long and 40 feet high this
digital ceiling makes for a spectacular
entrance but first visitors will pass
through these 16 ton thirty seven foot
tall bronze doors with text from the
book of Genesis with eight levels of
twenty two-foot high ceilings the museum
is the equivalent of a 17-story building
so this is the whole Bible from first
page to the last first page slice Carrie
summers is the museum's president we
wanted something close to the mall we
didn't pick this building unlike some I
said because we're close to the Capitol
some 51,000 donors contributed to the
construction of the museum but the
largest and most controversial donor is
Hobby Lobby the Arts and Crafts chain
founded by the conservative Christian
Green family this is not the Steve green
Muse Museum of the Bible
it's not Steve green is the president of
Hobby Lobby which has amassed over 40
thousand ancient biblical artifacts one
of the largest private biblical
collections in the world about a
thousand of them from Dead Sea Scrolls
to Bibles over a thousand years old will
be on display here the collection itself
has been the subject of controversy this
summer Hobby Lobby agreed to forfeit
thousands of pieces from its collection
and pay three million dollars after it
was discovered the items had been
smuggled into the u.s. from the Middle
East
obviously mistakes happened and we were
willing to pay the fine Greene insists
that the museum does not approach the
Bible from a particular viewpoint the US
Capitol is over your shoulder somebody
said the goal here is to knock down that
wall between church and state anything
to that well no because I think there is
a separate role for the church in the
state and it's not the state's role to
espouse of faith you have said that
Americans are as ignorant of the Bible
now as they have ever been I believe
that they are and I think primarily
because we don't teach it in our schools
as we once did you get to learn history
through seeing it feeling it and it's
just amazing there is a higher calling
here to cutting-edge technology and
special effects hop aboard the flyboard
theater and experience the sensation of
flying through washington DC indeed i
tremble for my country view the
scripture passages inscribed on federal
buildings it's awesome to see the
influence that christianity has had in
this country the museum invites you to
walk through the history of the bible
the olive trees in this village of
nazareth are modeled after the biblical
Garden of Gethsemane you believe the
Bible is good for the world yeah I do
it's good and the bad the ugly and then
you make up your own mind
some critics on the Left say this museum
will be full of evangelical propaganda
but some evangelicals say there's not
enough about Jesus in this museum the
people behind the museum say if they're
being criticized on the left and the
right they must be right in the middle
right where they want to be Gael well
you learn you can't please everybody
chip your chip we thank you